ah
el 10 de abril los franceses están
convocados a las urnas para elegir al
próximo presidente de la república por
eso viaje con nosotros alrededor de toda
francia a bordo de esta réplica del
clásico auto francés en una versión 100%
eléctrica así conoceremos en primera
persona los temas que preocupan a los
electores bienvenidos a elecciones 2022
un tour por francia vámonos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
nuestro autor por francia comienza aquí
en estrasburgo la capital de la región
del gran este en la frontera con al
humano
[Música]
con martín y clima nws la salud es un
tema de preocupación diaria
[Música]
aceptamos a pacientes de kobe pero
también a otros no se sale intacto de
una crisis compuesta al comienzo de la
pandemia aquí hubo una explosión de
casos de kobe 19 y también de decesos el
reputado sistema de salud francés mostró
aquí sus fallas pero conozcamos más
datos sobre la salud en francia
el 2020 francia gastó más de 209.000
millones de euros en insumos médicos ya
sea en hospitales medicina familiar
medicamentos o transportes sanitarios
esto representa una media de 3 mil 109
euros por habitante y un 9% del pib
este año 387 mil camas de hospital
estaban disponibles en francia- casi
seis camas por cada 1000 habitantes es
más que en el reino unido donde hay un
poco más de dos camas por cada mil
habitantes
pero es menos que en alemania donde hay
casi ocho camas por igual cantidad de
personas
este número de camas ha ido disminuyendo
en francia y eso mucho antes de la
pandemia del cómic 19 desde la década de
2000 los establecimientos médicos
públicos han perdido un cuarto de su
capacidad tras la crisis el coronavirus
el gobierno ha prometido 19 mil millones
de euros de inversión en los hospitales
y en los hogares de ancianos en un plazo
de 10 años este plan incluye un aumento
de 183 euros mensuales del salario neto
por mes para un millón y medio de
trabajadores de la salud
después de dos años de kobe la salud es
uno de los cuatro temas que más preocupa
a los franceses de cara a las
presidenciales
[Música]
con martín y clima nws la salud es un
tema de preocupación diaria
del otro lado mi mamá se enfermó el año
pasado y mi hermano trabaja en las
urgencias
verdaderamente todo lo que tiene que ver
con el hospital público me interesa
y es un tema al que le pongo mucha
atención de cara a estas elecciones
[Música]
no existe
nuestro sistema era enviado por todo el
mundo
y vimos que no estábamos a la altura de
lo que podía pasar
hoy hice para usted donde escribí
se necesitan recursos para tener un
sistema de salud correcto hospitales que
funcionen con un personal que esté bien
pagado porque es algo vital para la
gente en el país
la mayoría de los pacientes kovic del
gran este fueron tratados en los
hospitales públicos los mismos donde
desde antes de la crisis los
profesionales se quejaban de falta de
personal y de recursos insuficientes nos
acompaña el doctor y manuel andrés
presidenta de la comunidad médica de los
hospitales universitarios de estrasburgo
que agrupa a siete establecimientos
buenos días doctor andrés
doctor aquí comenzó la pandemia en
francia como se dieron afectados
estrasburgo y la región del gran este en
nuestro caso comenzó de manera más
fuerte en febrero tuvimos algo de suerte
en medio de nuestra desgracia porque
primero ocurrió en italia
muy cerca de nosotros en el alto run así
que contamos con un poco de tiempo para
prepararnos tuvimos una inmensa ola de
pacientes cobit que no nos esperábamos
que el un salto tipo doctor como se
organizaron para hacer frente a esta
avalancha de pacientes que además tenían
una enfermedad completamente desconocida
era una enfermedad nueva y teníamos muy
pocos datos algunos de china y otros
datos de los italianos que se vieron
afectados antes que nosotros así que de
entrada tuvimos que dedicar casi el 90%
de todos los recursos de nuestro
hospital a la atención de los pacientes
para darle un ejemplo durante esa
primera ola nos hicimos cargo de dos mil
pacientes de los cuales 500 estuvieron
en reanimación y nos adaptamos día a día
tratamos siempre de ir un paso adelante
siempre hacíamos nuestro plan de tareas
cotidianas con 2 o 3 días de
anticipación
no teníamos camas disponibles por si
acaso y con esa estrategia lo logramos
nos adaptamos con el paso del tiempo y
actuamos con agilidad para superar esa
ola que fue monstruosa
mons hasta antes de la pandemia los
franceses creían tener el mejor sistema
de salud del mundo que dejó en evidencia
la pandemia estaban engañados los
franceses el kobe está oculto eso porque
todos los profesionales realmente se
involucraron con mucha solidaridad y
profesionalismo durante los dos años que
acabamos de vivir así que es oculto un
poco los movimientos sociales porque
cuando uno está entre comillas en el
centro de la acción se ocupa ante todo
de los pacientes de la calidad y la
seguridad de los cuidados y un poco
menos
yo presido la comisión médica del
establecimiento de mi hospital y diría
que los centros hospitalarios de
estrasburgo sobrevivieron a la crisis y
al final logramos aceptar a todos los
pacientes que necesitaban el servicio
aceptamos a pacientes de kobe pero
también a otros
no se sale intacto de una crisis como
esta como le dije ya había crisis
sociales al principio dos años de lucha
son algo complicado las personas están
cansadas extenuadas se ve que hay algo
de desapego
una cierta pérdida de interés por la
labor las personas están cansadas pero
el sistema resistió
como ve usted el futuro del sistema de
salud francés
yo soy optimista por naturaleza así que
no hay de qué preocuparse creo que esta
es una profesión magnífica yo quería ser
médico desde que era un niño nunca diría
lo contrario sigo convencido de eso
creo que si habla con una enfermera ella
también le dirá que está convencida de
su trabajo ahora es necesario invertir a
los seres humanos eso es muy importante
creo que los profesionales de la salud
no sólo esperan mejoras salariales sino
tal vez más formación para ellos así
pueden desarrollar habilidades progresan
en distintos niveles tal vez trabajar
más en equipo tener más bienestar en el
lugar de trabajo y además hacer
proyectos que unan a los equipos
y pienso que con todos esos elementos
que se promueven en el seguro de la
salud deberíamos poder seguir
despertando interés por la labor y
además sentimos que los jóvenes sigan
presentes
abogó durante activity y esperemos que
pase algo similar a lo que ocurrió en el
momento de los atentados en francia
cuando desafortunadamente nos vimos
afectados pero después hubo una ola de
compromiso en el ámbito de la justicia
de la policía de los bomberos ahora
vemos que hay un ansia entre muchos
jóvenes que quieren estar al servicio de
los pacientes
james moody cuyo en que su ex hogar
muchas gracias doctor andrés por
concedernos esta entrevista
[Música]
7 millones de franceses no tienen
atención médica de cercanía garantizada
es lo que se conoce como vivir en un
desierto me dijo en algunas comunas
incluso es todo un problema cuando el
médico del pueblo se jubila la historia
es de karina ya vos
esta ciudad en las montañas de los
bosques no ha tenido un médico general
desde hace dos años
para atraer candidatos la ciudad ha
invertido de manera masiva convirtiendo
este hotel en un centro médico
este centro puede ser utilizado por tres
médicos
los trabajos de construcción costaron
trescientos cincuenta mil euros la mitad
lo paga el municipio
estamos ansiosos por ver este lugar
funcionando hay gran necesidad de
servicios médicos que en esta área
muchos están luchando sin un médico a su
alcance este paciente ha logrado
conseguir una cita con un fisioterapeuta
no puedo conducir en este momento así
que necesito pedirle a la gente que me
lleve a lugares si no hay un médico
cerca es muy molesto para todos
hay un médico a unos 7 kilómetros de
aquí pero está tan ocupado que no puede
aceptar nuevos pacientes la ciudad ha
intentado contratar profesionales de la
salud
desde el 2018 nos hemos gastado casi 11
mil euros en anuncios clasificados
ni siquiera eso ha dado resultados la
ciudad recurrió a una agencia de
contratación internacional pagando 30
mil euros para intentar encontrar un
médico extranjero que aceptara
instalarse en la ciudad antes la agencia
solía encontrar médicos exclusivamente
en europa del este ahora se está
centrando también en el sur de europa
principalmente grecia
los residentes aislados al menos tienen
su farmacia local que les proporciona
medicamentos
nos dan recetas médicas en consulta
eso es en cierto modo parte de su
trabajo lo que es realmente útil es
poder obtener mis medicamentos de uso
continuo incluso cuando no obtuve una
nueva prescripción
hace tres años la farmacia instaló un
computador para que sus clientes
pudieran realizar vídeo consultas
me sugirieron que consiguiera este tipo
de consulta hasta que un médico pudiera
venir a la ciudad se suponía que me
visitaría cada tres meses pero nunca
hemos visto a nadie así que sigo
teniendo estas consultas por vídeo
chritian es de 62 años tiene una cita
para controlar su problema de diabetes
como el 30 residentes utilizan estos
vídeos consultas con la esperanza de que
algún día un médico los examinó en
persona
y hasta aquí este primer capítulo de
elecciones 2022 un tour por francia
próxima parada marsella donde hablaremos
de cultura nos vemos
[Música]